entrepreneurship is an advanced strategy
you need to go and work for an
entrepreneur you need to go and do 6
months with this company 6 months with
this company you need to go fishing
around entrepreneurship is not some
Ticket To Riches entrepreneurship is a
really good ticket to be stressed all
the time to sit up late thinking about
your business to get really freaked out
about whether customers like stuff or
not you know entrepreneurship is is an
advanced move it's something that you
should do you you should actually be an
entrepreneur begrudgingly you should go
there's this thing that has to happen in
the world no one's doing it I'm going to
do it you know it's a bumpy road ends
smooth it's not a smooth Road it's not
for everyone and there are 6 million
businesses already in the UK there's 30
million plus in the in the USA go and
join a team stop trying to get a job at
Goldman Sachs where you're going to be
shoved in a corner and you're not going
to know how that business runs or what
you know who makes the decisions or
where things come from go work with a
team of eight
people